scusi m avete lembi di questo la m
maurizio ss.ll di xl xxl la cgil la dhl
nola m non c'è mi spiace ok ma non sa
neanche in un altro zara
attualmente la trovi solo a parigi che
faccio tra metto da parte fa niente no
grazie esclusi invece questa questo ci
aspetta un ora e mezza in questo esatto
puntotel a faccia arrivare va bene ciao
visto questa borsa online dove la poste
trovare guarda tutto quello che abbiamo
esposto cioè se non lo vedi non c'è e
poi voglio dirle vista online comprare
online
ciao infatti gliel'ho detto se l'ultimo
arrivato la pausa pranzo la fai per
ultimo la questione proprio di gerarchie
69 euro e 90 posso chiudere fattura hai
bisogno di fatture un responsabile
vendite in cassa signore defar fattura
scusa scusa se sabato il prof